> TOPPING OUR NATIONAL LEAD
TODAY, CONTRADICTORY STATEMENTS
FROM IDAHO POLICE ARE CREATING
CONFUSION 18 DAYS AFTER FOUR
UNIVERSITIES OF IDAHO STUDENTS
WERE FOUND DEAD IN THEIR
APARTMENT.
HUNDREDS CAME TOGETHER IN A
MOVING VIGIL LAST NIGHT WHERE
FAMILIES OF THE SLAIN STUDENTS
SHARED MEMORIES AND MOMENTS OF
SILENCE.
CNN'S VERONICA IS IN IDAHO,
SCRUTINIZING FOR NOT ONLY A LACK
OF PROGRESS IN SOLVING THE CASE
BUT CONFUSING A GRIEVING PUBLIC.
>> WE STILL BELIEVE IT'S A
TARGETED ATTACK.
>> Reporter: FROM THE BEGINNING,
POLICE REPEATEDLY CALLING THE
STABBING DEATHS OF FOUR
UNIVERSITY OF IDAHO STUDENTS A
TARGETED ATTACK, EVEN ISSUING A
STATEMENT SAYING EVIDENCE
INDICATES THAT THIS WAS A
TARGETED ATTACK.
>> SOMEBODY TARGETED THESE
INDIVIDUALS FOR SOME REASON.
>> Reporter: BUT LAST NIGHT, A
NEW STATEMENT LED TO CONFUSION
ABOUT WHETHER THE POLICE STOOD
BY THAT THEORY.
THE DEPARTMENT POSTING
DETECTIVES DO NOT CURRENTLY KNOW
IF THE RESIDENTS OR ANY
OCCUPANTS WERE SPECIFICALLY
TARGETED BUT CONTINUED TO
INVESTIGATE.
THAT STATEMENT BROUGHT A FLURRY
OF HEADLINES SUGGESTING POLICE
WERE DOING AN ABOUT FACE.
THEY TELL CNN THEIR POST WAS IN
RESPONSE TO COMMENTS MADE BY
PROSECUTOR BILL THOMPSON WHO
SAID IN AN INTERVIEW THAT THE
HOME OF THE VICTIMS AND
SPECIFICALLY ONE OR TWO OF THE
ROOMMATES MAY HAVE BEEN
TARGETED.
THAT ALONE IS WHAT POLICE SAY
THEY ARE CLARIFYING, TELLING CNN
WE REMAIN CONSISTENT IN OUR
BLEACH THAT THIS WAS INDEED A
TARGETED ATTACK BUT HAVE NOT
CONCLUDED IF THE TARGET WAS THE
RESIDENTS OR ITS OCCUPANTS.
THE POLICE CHIEF CONFIRMING THAT
THIS MORNING.
>> WHY YOU BELIEVE IT WAS
TARGETED OR THE REASONS ARE SO
CRUCIAL TO THE INVESTIGATION
THAT THEY CANNOT BE REVEALED?
>> WE ARE NOT GOING TO REVEAL
THAT.
THAT'S PART OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
TRYING TO PULL THE PIECES IN
THAT WILL HELP GIVE US THE
BEFORE, THE DURING AND THE
AFTER.
>> Reporter: POLICE HAVE TOLD
ALL OF THE CARS FROM IN FRONT OF
THE HOME, AND CONFIRMED THEY
RECEIVED SOME LAB TESTS BACK
FROM THE CRIME SCENE THOUGH THEY
WON'T SAY WHAT THEY ARE.
MEANWHILE, THE MOSCOW COMMUNITY
IS IN MOURNING AS THEY GATHERED
AT A CANDLELIGHT VIGIL WEDNESDAY
NIGHT.
SEVERAL OF THE VICTIMS' FAMILIES
SPOKE ABOUT THEIR TREMENDOUS
LOSS.
>> THE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT BRING
US HERE TONIGHT, THEY'RE
TERRIBLE.
THE HARDEST PART, WE CANNOT
CHANGE THE OUTCOME.
>> Reporter: AND THEY ALSO SPOKE
ABOUT WHAT COMFORTS THEM DURING
THIS DIFFICULT TIME.
>> THEY SHARED EVERYTHING.
THEY EVENTUALLY GET INTO THE
SAME APARTMENT TOGETHER.
AND IN THE END, THEY DIED
TOGETHER.
IN THE SAME ROOM, IN THE SAME
BED.
>> Reporter: AND JAKE, THE HEAVY
POLICE PRESENCE CONTINUES HERE
IN THE COMMUNITY OF MOSCOW AND
ON CAMPUS, BUT FOR HOW MUCH
LONGER AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
IDAHO, THAT IS UNCLEAR.
STUDENTS GET OUT NEXT WEEK FOR
THE REST OF THE SEMESTER AND
THEY DON'T COME BACK UNTIL MID
JANUARY.
THE UNIVERSITY OF IDAHO TELLS ME
THEY ARE GOING TO BE REVISITING
THEIR SECURITY PLANS AS INVEST
UNFOLDS.
JAKE.
>> LET'S BRING IN CNN COUNTER
TERRORISM ANALYST, AND FORMER
FBI SENIOR INTELLIGENCE OFFICER
PHIL MUDD, WE KNOW THAT DNA TEST
RESULTS ARE STARTING TO COME IN.
DO YOU HAVE ANY CONFIDENCE THAT
A SUSPECT COULD BE IDENTIFIED IN
THE NEXT FEW DAYS AS A RESULT OF
THAT?
>> I WOULD NOT SAY CONFIDENCE.
HOPE MIGHT BE A BETTER TERM.
LOOK, THERE'S GOING TO BE A LOT
OF DATA YOU HAVE TO LOOK
THROUGH.
WE KNOW THERE'S SIX RESIDENTS
THERE.
THERE'S ALSO REPORTS THERE'S A
LOT OF SOCIAL ACTIVITY AT THE
HOUSE.
HOW MUCH DNA, FOR EXAMPLE, HAIRS
FROM OTHER PEOPLE PICKED UP.
CAN YOU DETERMINE WHETHER THOSE
HAIRS WERE FROM VISITORS AT A
PARTY TWO WEEKS AGO OR WHETHER
THOSE HAIRS WHO ARE NOT FROM THE
PEOPLE IN THE HOUSE MIGHT BE
RELATED TO THE KILLER.
I THINK THAT'S GOING TO TAKE
SOME TIME.
ON THE REVERSE, JAKE, I WOULD
SAY IF YOU HAVE FOUR PHYSICAL
ATTACKS WITH INTERACTION,
INCLUDING DEFENSIVE WOUNDS ON
THE MURDER VICTIMS, THE CHANCE
THAT THE KILLER THOUGHT ENOUGH
AHEAD TO LEAVE NO EVIDENCE THAT
POLICE COULD FIND, I'M HOPING
THEY FIND SOMETHING BECAUSE
THAT'S A LOT OF PHYSICAL
INTERACTION TO LEAVE NOTHING
BEHIND, JAKE.
>> THAT'S WHAT I'M WONDERING.
ARE YOU SURPRISED THAT 18 DAYS
LATER, THERE'S BEEN, AS FAR AS
WE CAN TELL NO SUSPECT NAMED, NO
WEAPON FOUND?
IT'S ALMOST THREE WEEKS.
MAYBE THE PUBLIC HAS BEEN
SPOILED FROM ENTERTAINMENT
VERSIONS OF INVESTIGATIONS AND
MAYBE 18 DAYS IS ACTUALLY NOT
THAT LONG, BUT GIVE US YOUR
TAKE.
>> I WOULD SAY BEYOND SURPRISED.
VERY SURPRISED BECAUSE YOU'RE
NOT JUST TALKING ABOUT THE MANY
INTERVIEWS WITH FRIENDS AND
FAMILY, YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A
RELATIVELY SMALL COMMUNITY.
BUT IN THE DIGITAL AGE, YOU CAN
TRACK EVERYTHING OR A LOT OF
WHAT THESE YOUNG PEOPLE WERE
DOING IN THE PREVIOUS WEEK
THROUGH THINGS LIKE TEXT
MESSAGES.
WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF VIDEO FROM
THE LOCATIONS THEY WERE AT
BEFORE, WHICH NOT ONLY ALLOWS US
TO LOOK AT THE TIME LINE OF
WHERE THEY WERE, BUT WHO THEY
TALKED TO.
YOU KNOW EVERY PERSON THEY TOOK
A CLASS WITH IN THE LAST YEAR,
TWO YEARS.
YOU KNOW EVERY NEIGHBOR THEY
HAVE HAD FOR YEARS, SO IN THE
DIGITAL AGE, YOU CAN GET A
TRAIL.
YOU CAN GET A PATTERN OF LIFE
FAR DIFFERENT THAN YOU COULD
HAVE 20 YEARS AGO, AND WITH THE
AMOUNT OF INVESTIGATION ON THIS,
TO NOT HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
ADVANCE.
I'M NOT CRITICIZING THE POLICE.
I AM SAYING THAT'S PRETTY
SURPRISING.
>> THE FBI HAS BEEN
INVESTIGATING ALONGSIDE THE
LOCAL IDAHO POLICE MOSTLY
HELPING GATHERING TIPS, WE'RE
TOLD.
DO YOU THINK THE FBI SHOULD HAVE
A BIGGER ROLE IN THIS CASE,
PERHAPS A MORE PUBLIC ROLE,
PERHAPS EVEN THE PRIMARY ROLE,
CONSIDERING, A, HOW LITTLE
APPARENT PROGRESS THERE HAS BEEN
MADE ALMOST THREE WEEKS INTO
THIS, AND B, THE FACT THAT THE
POLICE HAVE BEEN MAKING SOME
INCONSISTENT STATEMENTS?
>> I DON'T THINK THE FBI SHOULD
HAVE A MORE SIGNIFICANT ROLE
UNLESS THE STATE AND LOCALS ASK
FOR A MORE SIGNIFICANT ROLE.
THE FBI HAS RELATIONSHIPS WITH
10,000 POLICE DEPARTMENTS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
THAT HAS EVERYTHING TO DO WITH
THINGS LIKE ABDUCTIONS TO BANK
ROBBERIES TO SUPPORT IN THIS
CASE, FOR MURDERS.
THE TYPICALLY ROLE FOR THE FBI,
IF THERE'S A LOCAL CASE AND THEY
WANT ASSISTANCE, WE PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE.
IF THE FBI GOT IN POSITION OF
TELLING POLICE DEPARTMENTS WE'RE
TAKING OVER BECAUSE WE THINK
YOU'RE INCOMPETENT, I DON'T WANT
TO SEE THAT WORLD BECAUSE THE
COOPERATION WITH LOCAL POLICE
DEPARTMENTS WOULD DECLINE
DRAMATICALLY.
>> IS IT TRUE THAT THE LONGER
THIS GOES ON, THE TOUGHER IT
WILL BE TO FIND THE KILLER?
>> YEAH, THAT'S GOING TO BE
TRUE.
I MEAN, YOU LOOK AT THE CASE
RESOLUTION RATES AND EVERYTHING
IN THE DATA WILL SHOW YOU THAT.
THERE'S A FLIP SIDE OF THIS, AND
THAT IS IF YOU LOOK AT THINGS
LIKE THE FBI'S MOST WANTED
CATEGORY OF PEOPLE, ANYBODY WHO
DID THIS WHO THINKS THEY CAN
COVER THEIR TRACK FOR A YEAR OR
FIVE YEARS OR TEN YEARS, THE
DATA DON'T BARE THAT OUT.
IF THERE'S A HIGH END
INVESTIGATION WHERE
INVESTIGATORS HUNT FOR YEARS,
THE CHANCE, EVEN IF WE HAVE THE
TRAG